Don Van Natta has been an investigative
reporter for ESPN since 2012 back here
on the show how are you doing Don great
retch how are you today how did this
news hit the NFL best you can tell
they're thrilled it's it's really
fascinating you know the old saying be
careful what you wish for this is be
grateful for what you didn't wish for
really yeah the NFL executives are
thrilled
the owners are thrilled they see this as
a way to drive engagement and increase
fan interest in every single play
because there will be wagering in these
legal sports books around the country
rich what they call in the UK in running
betting so you can you can bet on
whether a field goal is hit or miss you
can bet on over and under on a punt and
so they see the possibilities of it I
mean they're they're thrilled about what
it's going to do for fan engagement but
at the same time they also are tempering
expectations of how much more money is
going to put in everybody's pockets but
they're they're absolutely thrilled that
this went this way well I gotta tell you
Don I mean that is completely anathema
to the NFL that I have been around over
the last I guess 14 plus years where did
this
I guess turnabout come from do you think
well as wise you know rich Jerry Jones
and Robert Kraft two of the most
influential and arguably most powerful
owners in the league were early
investors in draft Kings I think there
was a sense among the owners that this
was coming and as you know the NFL is
very very good at figuring out a way to
monetize anything and everything and you
know this past March at an owners
meeting that was held in Orlando Eric
groopman the longtime NFL executive vice
president gave a presentation to the
owners during that meeting on gambling
and what it would mean for the league
Grubin had spent about a year working on
it he studied the legal bookmakers in
the UK and in Europe and he got the
owners ready for what by then everyone
saw was likely coming from the Supreme
Court which we saw yesterday but at the
same time Richie lowered the
expectations on revenues
it's really the it's really the
non-measurable money that they're going
to see down the road when of course the
broadcast deals come up in 2022 and if
the ratings go up in and they expect
that they will want a lot of these
online bookmakers around the country
begin operating then they see that as a
bump that they'll see down the road you
know Mark Cuban yesterday I believe said
that the NFL franchises instantly
doubled in value and there were some
chortling among the people I talked to
yesterday in the smoker and this morning
about that among the NFL executives they
don't think that's true but certainly
they like the the long horizon view of
what this means for valuations for
broadcast deals for fan engagement for
television ratings on the inside a
report with Don Van Natta of senior
writer espn.com ESPN the magazine senior
investigative reporter so then how does
that square with the public statements
about the NFL concerned for the
integrity of the game well it does
square in the sense that what they talk
about is because the gambling will no
longer be offshore that the the NFL will
now be partners with these bookmakers
and they'll be able to actually monitor
betting patterns in a more a far more
transparent way than it is now and they
certainly are still talking about that
rich as you know that's been Roger
Goodell mantra forever and they're still
very very concerned about that but they
feel it will be a lot easier to do that
particularly if the bookmakers use the
official data of the NFL and that is a
revenue stream that they are expecting
to get so you're going to still hear a
lot about the integrity of the game and
how important that is but you know this
is now the law of the land and so the
NFL is going to figure out a way to
monetize it and those discussions began
long before yesterday and and there's
just a lot of optimism about what this
will do for fan engagement well in terms
of so how does it work cuz Brent
Musburger who's my next guests on this
show when we mentioned a few months ago
Adam Silver's idea posited in a op-ed
that there would be some form of
integrity feel though it wasn't the use
that he
that he used but it sounds like one a
percentage would go to the league from
all the bookmakers brent musburger
laughed at that and said that certainly
wouldn't happen in his in his mind or
speaking to anybody that he knows and
certainly since it hasn't happened in
Las Vegas and sports betting has been
legal there forever so how does this
work
monetarily yeah yeah well that's that's
a great question rich and and I think
Brent Musburger was on the money in
laughing at it the discussions that I've
had yesterday and this morning the NFL
is I believe going to make an
announcement pretty soon here in the
coming days or weeks that they're
opposed to any integrity fee they just
don't think in integrity to you know 1%
off the top of wagering is in anyone's
interest they say practically speaking
it doesn't work from a political
perspective because no legislature knows
legislature is going to want to be seen
shoveling money use it Jerry Jones and
Robert Kraft and billionaire owners it
just doesn't work politically for them
they also don't like the idea that the
legislators can at some point you know
pull the rug out from this in a year or
two if they need to and and they don't
like the idea of legislators being in
charge of determining a piece of their
revenue pie it's a business model that
the NFL feels that they don't have any
control over and that's the last thing
that they want the other interesting
thing about the 1% from the NFL's
perspective as I understand it rich is
they see it as another fee that would go
on top of that 10 percent Vig so it the
way they see it if the tape out by the
bookmakers these legal bookmakers around
the country is too high then the illegal
offshore bookmakers will still offer
more value to the gambler and won't get
but won't get put out of business but so
interesting about this now is the NFL is
really wants the illegal bookmakers
which of course helped turbocharged fan
interest for so many years he put out of
business and they want the state
sanctioned legal bookmakers at
racetracks and casinos to put those
folks out of business for the
transparency reasons I said and the way
to do that is to keep the Vig down so
you know it's a brave new world when the
NFL suddenly concerns the legal better
we'll get a fair
shake what aligned on so so is the NFL
gonna be the the league that that takes
the lead here and all the other league's
fallen behind with the same model or is
baseball gonna try and do what's best
for it NBA I mean how does all this come
together the best you can tell I don't I
don't I'm not sure that's a really good
question because you know Adam silver is
pretty adamant that this is NBA content
and they should be paid for it with this
either 1% integrity fear it's a royalty
fee whatever you want to call it or a
quarter percent I think it's been the
discussion in West Virginia of what it
is and so there I think there's a split
here and it'll be very interesting to
see how this plays out in state houses
around the country if you have you know
two of the four major American sports
leagues saying they want some kind of
integrity for you know at least the NFL
is not interested in that
Don Van Natta here in the Honda inside a
report from ESPN senior investigative
reporter so you just hit on the
statehouses here because I'm imagining
before the league's can figure out how
they get a piece the states are already
just gonna start this thing with New
Jersey just right around the corner how
quickly do you think fans who are
listening taking in this show will be in
their states close to or about to or
going to be able to put supports
Campbell Don well I think in New Jersey
it's going to be just a matter of a
couple of weeks I know that legislation
was already introduced yesterday in New
Jersey to put together the regulatory
framework to get people wagering maybe
as early as early June so folks in New
Jersey can go to Mama's Park and bet on
the NBA Finals five states have already
passed legislation anticipating this
decision by the Supreme Court besides
New Jersey its Pennsylvania Connecticut
West Virginia and Mississippi I think in
a matter of months we'll see those
states online so you'll be able to bet
on the NFL this fall in those states
most most likely and then there's
another 15 to 20 states that have
introduced legislation and among them or
New York California
in Michigan Illinois you know big state
South Carolina but that may be a year to
two years before their online rich but I
mean the best estimate that I kept
hearing from the lobbyists is they're
hopeful that by 2023 in about five years
we'll be about thirty two states
thirty to thirty two states offering
regulating regulated sports betting in
this country and you know we're headed
to what you know in the UK is you know
you go to London there's a betting shop
on every corner you know that's where
we're headed
and that's the model by the way that the
NFL studied is exactly how it's handled
in in the UK and in the UK you can bet
as a soccer match is going on you can
bet on all sorts of things live as it's
happening and if you're a gambler that
can be a lot of fun it also run up the
debt pretty fast and what about daily
fantasy done they got to be ecstatic
right in that world they're absolutely
ecstatic rich draftkings and FanDuel
which have you know really struggled I
did a piece about them in 2016 and they
were really thrown for a loop then but
it was always a long-term bet with some
of the investors of those two companies
that I spoke with that this day would
come sports wagering would be approved
by the Supreme Court and there's ten
million users that draftkings has and
they already have this platform set up
and these are engaged folks who love to
wager on daily fantasy and so they're
obviously going to try to turn those
people into sports gamblers on their
platforms so it's I mean it's the
lifeline that those two companies needed
for sure
last one for you Don the league meeting
the mailee meeting next week in the NFL
and so do you think that what you said
to kick off this Honda inside a report
that it's ecstatic that it's not be
careful what you wish for but you know
enjoy what you thought you didn't want
it will that be a face forward message
from the NFL ownership membership or
even the Commissioner next week as they
welcome David Tepper into their mix the
new owner of the Carolina Panthers I
don't know if they'll be expressing the
thrills that I'm hearing quietly on the
phone at the league meeting next week in
Atlanta rich
you know roger goodell you know chooses
his words very carefully he's been a
longtime opponent of this but certainly
behind a closed door you know they're
pleased and and and and not that
surprised they saw it coming even though
of course they've been opposed to this
in the courts for so long
and now that it's here they're going to
do what they always do and that's
monetize it as the best they can and
they're as we both know they're very
very good at it monetizing Jannetty our
TV audience just saw mr. Tepper up on
the screen there he's gonna coast
through correct he's gonna be welcomed
into the absolutely yes and the fact
that the team is staying in carolina
everyone is pleased about that and the
thing i'm surprised about is the price
tag the 2.2 billion dollar price tag is
a little lower than i think some of the
expectations were there was numbers as
high as three billion being kicked
around a few months ago so i but from
some people's view that she got a
bargain at 2.2 billion dollars well it's
because of to two words dawn that two
words are in cash correct that's how you
get a little bit of a bargain when you
say how about 2.2 i instead of 2.8 how
about 2.2 in cash that's right you get
the cash we've we've all bought and sold
houses in cash those are those the best
words you can you donc thank you sir
really appreciate a great great chatting
with you as always thank you rich you
bet that's Don Van Natta the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience